This building means
so many things.
It means keeping a commitment.
It means bringing better, more
efficient, and more coordinated
care for patients.
It means giving our
faculty a home that they
can be really proud to work in.
And it means a real
wonderful investment
in the city of Tucson.
Well, the great thing
about a facility like this
is that it brings together
not only primary care,
but subspecialties in a place
where patients have the most
convenience.
So they meet with their
primary care physician.
But if they need attention
from specialists,
they don't have to go all over
town to get that kind of help.
This will allow us to invest
in the technologies that
are going to make health care
easier so that life can get
better for our patients, really
emphasizing the human aspect
of health care.
And this is what this building
does because it feels really
like home.
And that's what we want
health care to feel like.
Another remarkable thing
about this building
is just part of
this transformation
of academic medicine
here in Tucson.
And so this gives
us an opportunity
to take advantage of
all those discoveries,
and new technologies, and
even new models of care,
and apply them to the people
here in Tucson and of course,
all the people who
get referred to us
from around the state and
even this part of the country.
So it's really an
exciting time for us
to be opening this new building.